okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about functions so functions is
definitely something that's emphasized
that you understand on the act and it
shows up in a couple different forms but
first let's talk about you know what is
a function
so a function is really just like an
equation
but it's written in such a way that you
can see that whatever's in the
parentheses here this x value that's the
input you're going to be putting that in
place of x on the right side of the
equation so say for example to say find
f of negative 2 what we're going to do
is we're going to put this negative 2 in
place of x now if you're doing this on
your calculator or even if you're doing
this by hand i recommend putting it in
parentheses so that it's treated as a
group so it's the whole thing negative 2
squared minus 3 times the whole thing
negative 2 plus 1. if you don't put it
in parentheses when you do it on your
calculator or even if you do by yourself
when you're doing that order of
operations it could give you a different
answer unless you take it as an entire
group like that so here we have a
negative 2 squared that means a negative
2 times a negative 2 so twice that's
positive 4 a negative 3 times a negative
2 is positive 6
plus 1 more so that's going to be 11. so
f of negative 2 equals 11. so it's just
a different way of writing an equation
instead of writing y equals we write it
as f of x or g of x or h of x so let's
look at a couple examples now you can
pause the video and try these on your
own i recommend that to get a little bit
more benefit from this but
do that and we'll come back and go over
it together
so this one it says that the function
here is given find the f of negative 1
what is f of negative 1 so whatever's in
parenthesis okay that's our x value
we're going to put that in for x on the
right so i'm going to replace
x with negative 1
okay now you can see i'm putting it in
parentheses and then we want to do the
order of operation the pemdas which we
talked about in an earlier lesson
you just take a negative 1 squared so
parentheses exponents then
multiplications that's important so
that's positive 1 because a negative 1
twice is positive one times negative
three is negative three that's going to
give us negative two
plus seven so that's a negative five
plus seven which is two so f of negative
one equals two
now this next example
see if you can get this one on your own
sometimes they throw this little
variation on on the func function
concept okay and uh but it's basically
the same idea so see if you can get this
one if a triangle b equals two a minus
three b squared what is three triangle
two equal
okay so
go ahead and pause the video
and we'll do it together so if we're
going to solve this
you can see the pattern here whatever's
in front of that triangle that's that's
3 and that's going to be our a value
right so i'm just going to put 3 in
place of a
and then whatever comes after the
triangle to the right of the triangle
that's our b value so you can see b is
2.
okay so really you can see the way
functions work it's just like a
substitution it tells you what your
input is and you go ahead and put that
value in and simplify so this is going
to be 2 times 3 is 6. 2 squared is 4
times 3 is 12. 6 minus 12 is negative 6
and you got it so definitely understand
how to work with functions it's an easy
one to get right on the act and
something that they'll they'll be
testing you on